[Music]
in 1996 we experienced our independence
day now
humanity had 20 years to prepare for the
return and this is the best movie they
could come up with but you tell me Mike
what was hanging out come on guys yeah
like one and a half boyhoods to get it
right
Independence Day resurgence you love
slash hated the originals blend of
quality and camp eNOS welcome to earth
thanks to Will Smith great effects and
the most epic speech ever today we
celebrate our Independence Day
[Music]
now gear up with return of none of those
things because now when you think
Independence Day think Judd Hirsch and a
road trip with an expanding cast of
orphans
so weird the aliens have returned for
our liquid hot magma I think they're
after our molten core and this time they
brought their own gravity pleases it has
its own gravity their own ecosystem
ecosystem the ability to give you a
wicked bad headache up against the ropes
earth is bringing back all your favorite
characters except your favorite
character featuring Will Smith's fake
movie son who was crippled by an
accident that left him entirely without
charisma we'll all try to converge at
the same time but whoever gets to the
target first will deliver the payload
one of those handsome Hemsworth brothers
because why not
Vivek a fox the only stripper in history
who wasn't lying about saving up for med
school Jeff Goldblum reprising his most
popular role himself so surprised CEO
little bed
and ex-president Whitmore who was found
to give a kick-ass speech topping the
last one any second now today he's gonna
do it just wait not any second now
that's sacred that's worth fighting for
oh here we go see random extras are
starting to watch we all have to fight
till our last breath and that is gonna
lead us to victory wait that's it that's
the big speech come on what happened to
we will not go quietly into the night
hit me with a good stuff you had 20
years
follow along for a script so bad Will
Smith chose to do Suicide Squad instead
with no detail too small to be blurted
out loud can you believe it you've been
in a coma for 73 hundred days entire
subplots that only exists to tell you
how much time is left we do not have
seven hours until the earth core breach
we only have one and set up for prequel
sequels and spin-offs that sound way
more interesting than the movie you're
currently watching they were hunting us
we have to learn how to hunt them oh I
want to see that one so strap in for the
sequel that's twice the size and half
the fun between an even bigger doomsday
weapon this one is definitely bigger
than the last one and even bigger
disposable CGI army and more of the
global destruction were completely numb
to at this point we get to this guy beam
guys oh oh there it is oh that was fun
starring pretty try for a white guy must
cash paycheck must catch paycheck trade
in Smith the most interesting man in the
world
Dumbo data rabbi bagel Rosenstein she's
a Killer Queen the Polka ball by Apple
the tragic school bus pandering to
Chinese audiences
integral to the earth space defense
program Bano moon milk thank you for
using q-tips need y'all young and baby
Thor's flying drawers
in dumb pendens day ships more than
3,000 miles in diameter oh the hell did
we miss this no seriously how did you
miss that it's the size of America and
the movie never explains how you missed
it you had 20 years to write this hey
screen junkies have you heard the news
screen junkies news we've launched a
second channel devoted to live breaking
entertainment news on YouTube click the
box to the left to check it out and
subscribe but that's not all we also
just launched a new show on screen
junkies plus starring our own Dan Merle
Dan's labyrinth click the Box on the
right to check it out and join the
conversation live every Monday
alluminium this is an announcer voice
announcing it's an announcer voice in an
announcer voice pardon me are you Aaron
Burr sir Dormammu
I've come to bargain don't blame me I
voted for kodos
I am the cutest puppy in the whole wide
world